good afternoon reject nation it's Craig
Alba here no I'm John we're watching a
trailer a second trailer for a movie
that I thought the first trailer look
good a lot of people didn't seem to
really care about it
Tomb Raider I'm excited to see this
other trailer right now I'm gonna get my
tickets a week in advance don't ask me
how but I'll figure it out by the way we
passed four thousand followers on the
Stardust at so thank you guys to
everyone who's been following us over
there we have over a hundred twenty
posts right now I am loving using it
it's an app that allows you to do 30
second reactions or reviews for an evil
TV show or trailer plenty of youtubers
are using this app right now - our goal
is to surpass all of them no matter what
we want to bring the Stardust territory
so download the app and follow us first
link in the description box and oh yes a
shout out today for patron Map beer
[Music]
[Music]
we are did a meeting great numbers what
are you doing here
[Music]
this is a cover
[Music]
[Music]
survival rate into
[Music]
nice teach looks badass
[Laughter]
[Music]
I don't like these weird Warner Brothers
trailer final moment I feel like I'm the
only one who's really looking forward to
this movie I think it looks like a
cheesy funtime tonally it's very
different than the other trailer trailer
is marketing Warner Brothers is known to
do that with those trailers mix it up
mix it up every time this is a lot more
that kind of female empowerment type of
trailer it's very much centered around
like her struggle both physically and
with you know her emotional struggling
in the beginning she's riding a bike
she's like a tomboy I like that element
and they have was that Destiny's Child
survivor cover you know you slap that on
there it kind of adds a cheesy element
but it also kind of works for me to have
it in the trailer because a big part of
Laura Croft and the Tomb Raider game is
survival especially the wilderness and
all that yeah yeah and especially the
newer Tomb Raider game that I think they
based a lot of this on you know yeah bag
them is about watching her grow into a
hero she's kind of in over her head at
first she has a lot to endure and I get
the sense of they're borrowing a lot
from that for this it does look like you
know the rise to becoming you know what
yeah I think of as Tomb Raider this
seems to be honoring a lot of that in
its own way I think the worry that I
have for this film is that's gonna try
to take itself too seriously you know
little and up coming across cheesy I
feel like this is gonna be a very
specific tone and balance you'll have to
try to find because a lot of times these
video game movies fail when they take
themselves so self-serious and then they
come out corny when I feel like you
can't accomplish a very serious movie
you can't accomplish a serious tone
right now what we're getting from the
trailer is cheesy fun that's what that's
the vibe I'm getting
although the moments that look really
interesting to me the ones that I'm
looking forward to her all the stuff
where she's going against an
environmental harsh conditions like when
she slams against the tree she's in the
river yeah
swinging through the trees like like
Shia LaBeouf and Indiana came through
the Crystal Skull stuff like that is are
the elements look cool because at the
end of the day as Laura Croft
Alicia vikander looks badass I don't
know about the rest of the movie but
Alicia vikander looks bad
and it would be alright with that if we
walk away from this being like an
alright movie but you know she really
shines in it or something like that I
can I can sort of see this being one of
those that maybe has some really
rewarding elements but might not come to
I don't know what's missing from this
trailer for me I guess but I I there's
something that keeps me from being like
I'm excited it's just a vibe I get but I
wonder if this is one of those that's
gonna take itself very seriously but not
have very interesting dialog from some
recent I got worries about this but the
production values all look great I like
the first trailer the more because it
was more fun I think this movie is
better off just kind of going with that
fun vibe with occasional moments of
badass seriousness as opposed to heavy
drama yeah maybe that's the thing about
these trailers I don't actually buy the
fun even though the trailers communicate
fun there's something about it that
makes me go I don't think this movie's
gonna be as fun as they want me to think
it's gonna be but I it could be
completely wrong it is just a feeling
that I get I'm hoping they go for fun
because right now when they try to take
it so super serious I just don't fully
buy it I'd rather have fun instead of oh
man they're not really succeeding in
that also - in comparison to like the
tomb raider movies that we got before
this does feel different it does have a
different vibe because it's based more
on the reboot of the games and also
Alicia vikander hasn't looked like it
has a much more lived-in Laura Croft a
more three-dimensional character as
opposed to video game portrayal yeah
yeah and I think she's a good actress I
think that's a good choice and
especially I mean the the redesign Tomb
Raider she looks a lot like her I'm
rooting for her
I feel like as long as she's great that
could be the big saving grace no matter
what the issues I along issues or plot
issues this has as long as she's great I
feel like that would be a big saving
grace for this film yeah
first first order of business for Tomb
Raider Movies to cat also patron of the
day shout out for Matthew beer now I
wanted to get Matt beer shout out on the
Tomb Raider video because if anyone's
like Laura cross at our patreon it's
this guy
Oh Matt beer is constantly raiding tombs
constantly going on wilderness
adventures constantly fighting against
bad guys this is the toughest guy we
know and he has a really dark
to death he does no Matt beer has the
simple good life he's a lovely fellow
with a good heart if anyone's gonna get
a Laura Croft it's this guy but in all
sincerity Matt what I love about you is
you've been big pledge of ours for
patron out for quite some time now and
you never asked for like anything I'm
always the one hitting you up to try to
like reward tutors but you never like
ask me anything
we appreciate just your overall support
I would appreciate you being loyal and
keeping following us and I hear you're
gonna be visiting here in a couple weeks
so make sure to hit us buddy anyway guys
you can subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification Bell to get
notified every time one of our videos is
up and make sure to download and follow
us on the Stardust at Seattle's we must
ruin the Stars and where's Nick Frost in
this trailer